le député l ère du haut rhin qui avait
été on s'en souvient l'un des premiers
du palais bourbon à être atteint par le
coronavirus selon luc reitzer est
aujourd'hui rentré chez lui après plus
de deux mois à l'hôpital
bonsoir jean luc reitzer vous êtes en
direct ou par téléphone en direct fierté
france merci d'être avec nous on le
disait vous avez été le premier
parlementaire à avoir été touchés par le
kobe première question comment
allez-vous le moins mal possible quand
on n'a pas su effectivement deux mois et
demi à l'hôpital avec quatre semaines de
coma profond
quand on a dû réapprendre toulouse s de
la vie quand on a perdu quelques vins
qu'ils osent lorsque l'on se réveille
après ce commun et qu'on arrive au bout
de deux mois de nouveau à pratiquement
avoir une situation je dirais presque
normal parce que je dois naturellement
encore séduire un certain nombre de soi
et puis des examens dans les semaines
qui viennent et dans les mois qui
viennent et bien je peux dire
effectivement que je me porte moins mal
possible et je voudrais avoir une pensée
pour tous ceux qui sont encore
hospitalisés une pensée aussi pour les
familles des disparus et souvent je
pense parce que moi même mon pronostic
vital est engagé à deux reprises ma
famille a passé des moments extrêmement
difficiles et quand je pense à toutes
ces familles qui ont été frappés et vous
avez si tous les chiffres à l'instant à
plus de 28000 dans notre pays qui n'ont
pas pu bénéficier non plus de deux
cérémonies qu'elle soit religieuse ou
civile
entourés de leur famille entourés de
leurs amis eh bien on mesure le drame
parce que ces familles n'ont pas pu
effectuer leur devoir de mémoire et le
travail de deuil
donc quand on est rescapé que moi j'ose
utiliser ce terme est bien on mesure la
chance que l'on a clairement jean luc
reitzer vous estimez que vous êtes un
miraculé côté moteur mais je ne peux pas
l'utiliser
néanmoins c'est vrai comme je voulais
dix à douze reprises mon
mon pronostic vital a été engagé puisque
dans le cadre de cette mise dans le coma
s'était tout de suite au début comme
vous l'avez rappelé j'étais le premier
parlementaire elle être infecté c'était
donc beau but mars surtout leur dormi au
puy en cours de coma on a voulu
commander mercy bay et ça s'est très
très mal passé j'étais effectivement
extrêmement agitées je ne pouvais plus
respirer tout ça ce sont les médecins
qui me l'ont dit après bien sûr moi je
ne m'en souviens pas donc on a été
obligé de leurs études au deuxième fois
ce qui est en général assez polis et
donc c'est à ce moment là que mon
pronostic vital a été engagé et que ma
famille surtout a beaucoup souffert
parce que d'heure en heure les
informations variées et étaient souvent
très alarmiste est très alarmante et
donc voilà c'est vrai que j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance terme miraculeux
peut-être peut-être exagéré mais c'est
vrai que je me suis super bien sortis
comme disaient les médecins me riders
vous venez de loin de très loin
y at il des moments vous avez perdu
espoir
oui il ya des moments où tu vraiment
j'ai perdu espoir lorsque j'avais
pendant de très nombreux jours voire
plusieurs semaines la possibilité de
tavannes et de déglutir je ne pouvais
plus boire pas boire même pas de look
je ne pouvais évidemment pas manger et
je ne vous cache pas qu'à ce moment là
effectivement le moral était au plus bas
et que la dépression n'était pas très
loin car si près loin ou donc à ce
moment-là je tiens à souligner le
caractère humain du personnel
hospitalier
j'ai naturellement mesure et le
professionnalisme des médias c'est eux
qui m'ont sauvé la vie les infirmières
les aides soignantes et personnes qui
sont venues dans la chambre tous les
jours pour la nettoyer pour désinfecter
ce qui devait l'être et bien d'y être
pas une de ces personnes qui passaient
dans ma chambre sans avoir un mot
d'encouragement et je me souviens
puisque vous parlions des moments
difficiles je me souviens effectivement
que lorsque moral était au plus bas bien
mais nous devons affirmer abonnés ne te
vire la même car elle ses bras remet d
orange rider ça reviendra
la licra mais comment ne savons pas
comment cette maladie n'est venu qu'est
ce que touche le cerveau elle peut
toucher le coeur et de toucher des reins
on ne savait pas comment cette maladie
pouvant évoluer donc moi j'avais
effectivement le doute et je me disais
demain si tu peux plus la valeur si tu
peux plus manger
elles seront encore le plaisir de la vie
et donc ce moment là est
particulièrement difficile à dire mais
le côté humain du personnel m'a
énormément énormément aidé je n'avais
pas de visite pendant deux mois j'ai vu
ma maman nous pose la première fois le
le 3 mai c'est à dire 12 mois après
après mon hospitalisation et encore de
loin dans le couloir donc quand on est
seul comme ça c'est très difficile à
vivre nous avaient toujours l'espoir
parce que je suis je suis un battant
et puis j'avais envie de vivre parce que
la vis au bout avec ses difficultés avec
ses joies avec chez fun mais la vie chez
vous et donc ça valait la peine de se
battre j'ai fait de mon mieux mais je
répète je pense surtout à ceux qui n'ont
pas pu gagner cette bataille et qu'ils
sont plus là j'en ai 13h aujourd'hui le
ségur de la santé s'est ouvert
injustement pour voir les hôpitaux les
soignants aujourd'hui vous voyez les
choses différemment vous soutenez plus
que jamais ces soignants dans leur lutte
pour que leurs conditions soient
meilleurs salaires pendant 34 ans de ma
ville la ville d'altkirch dans le haut
rhin
j'ai été président d'un conseil de
surveillance et d'administration de mon
hôpital josy mon hôpital tellement
j'étais attaché à celui ci est donc je
connais ce problème depuis de très
nombreuses années et je voulus office 12
ans effectivement bien sûr moyen qu'ils
soient humains qu'ils soient financiers
et nous sommes arrivés au maintenant un
point de rupture et donc il est
impératif que et sur la photo tout le
gouvernement à moi je suis je suis
député maire vous l'avez rappelé je met
tout le monde dans le même sac dans ce
domaine là nous avons tous
collectivement commis de graves erreurs
nous pensons toujours que moi il y avait
de mettre sa noire et puis moi ça
coûterait cher et bien c'est une grave
erreur on voit aujourd'hui que le
système implose et donc il faut
effectivement tirer les leçons de ce qui
s'est passé je tabac de l'histoire des
masaï à des commissions parlementaires
qui diront ce qui s'est passé nous
ferons
l'horizon revaloriser vraiment que vous
avez vu nous sommes dans dans le peloton
de queue en matière de niveau de vie de
lopes de le personnel hospitalier
ils sont réinvesties on n'a rien on a
investi beaucoup dans les années 90 mais
après on a plus beaucoup investi on a vu
le nombre de respirateur qui manquait
dans notre pays par rapport à
l'allemagne
et enfin ils font de nous rendre
attractives les professions de santé je
pense notamment à la présence de tout ça
en milieu rural et semi rural le fameux
numerus clausus qui vous plaît à poser
pendant de très nombreuses années
heureusement maintenant qu'on l'a enlevé
on a supprimé le surnommer route
résister qu'à l'heure actuelle nous
avons une connerie de médecins nous
avons une bonne hogra tri médical qui
est en pleine crise et donc il faut leur
apprendre la russie de me battre
activités que les collectivités aussi
s'engage en mettant à disposition des
locaux gratuitement faisant souvent
besoin financière pour permettre à tous
les médecins de s'installer pas
simplement de les grandes villes je
répète mais aussi en milieu rural et
semi rural ce sont les eaux sans que je
tire et je serai naturellement à la
pointe du combat dans les années qui
viennent pour faire prendre conscience
de la nécessité afin de prendre des
mesures concrètes et directes
jean luc reitzer sur un plan plus global
cette fois ci la gestion de la crise par
le gouvernement vous avez évoqué les
masques on pourrait aussi parler des
tests pour vous clairement le
gouvernement qu'il commis des erreurs
comme l'affirment beaucoup je vous ai
dit je pense que le temps n'est pas à la
polémique ce crise n'est pas terminée et
je voudrais rendre attentif tout le
monde et notamment l'eau chaude sur le
fait que la crise sanitaire que la
contagiosité de ce mur est sûr toujours
présent et donc il faut faire très
attention jeu paulo 17 un ennemi qui est
féroce
je n'occupe beaucoup en vue que le drame
de cette contagion et donc je rends tout
le monde attend ti sur la nécessité de
faire très attention et pour moi je vous
le répète c'est pas le moment de la
polémique
par contre il y aura des
commission d' enquête parlementaire qui
dans les semaines dans l'émoi viendront
et travailleront pour voir ce qui se
passait en tout cas il ya eu
manifestement en matière de match et
aussi en matière de test il ya eu
maldonne
mais le retard au démarrage il ya eu
peut-être aussi un certain nombre de
défaillances est ce que moi surtout j'ai
constaté sur le vécu après puisque toute
cette période difficile j'étais dans le
coma je n'ai pas vécu directement mais
ce que j'ai surtout constaté c'est que
nous avons une sur administration dans
notre pays
vous savez qu'il ya combien de centaines
de millions de masques étaient tout
simplement bloqués à roissy charles de
gaulle parce que le ministère du budget
de les appliquer des droits de douane
pour l'importation de ces masques alors
qu'on a manqué en france j'ai entendu
pendant mon hospitalisation à la
télévision comme ça l'est un petit haut
lieu j'ai entendu un industriel français
qui disait qu'il avait un test à tout ce
qui est validé ates qui tous vivants
dont simply et ne pouvait pas le vendre
en france parce que l'autorisation ne
lui était pas accordé par le ministère
de la santé la haute autorité de la
santé
il a vraiment un problème de sueur et
administration de lourdeur
je pense qu'il faudra là aussi en tirer
les leçons le plus rapidement possible
car ce plus pensable que nous puissions
prendre du retard par rapport à nos
voisins nous sommes quand même un pays
développé
nous avons des technologies
particulièrement en pointe et là
malheureusement dans la distribution des
masses dans la distribution des tests
nous étions là aussi dans la queue du
peloton et c'était triste à voir mais je
le regrette amèrement
merci beaucoup jean-luc un laser de nous
avoir accordé ce temps députés l ère du
haut-rhin merci à vous